ah
[Música]
a
a la conferencia episcopal de francia
propuso una compensación financiera de
las víctimas de pedofilia en la iglesia
una medida que las asociaciones de
víctimas venían pidiendo desde hace
mucho tiempo pero ante el anuncio no
quedaron contentas por una parte porque
se habla de compensación y no de
reparación dejando entender que la
iglesia no acepta aún su responsabilidad
por estos crímenes y también el origen
de los fondos que no serán las arcas de
la iglesia sino en la realidad de dones
que pedirán a los fieles en francia- se
estima que desde 1950 y al menos 10.000
menores que han sido víctimas de abuso
sexual en la iglesia esto según la
comisión que investiga estos casos y que
fue creada en 2018 precisamente cuando
se dieron a conocer varios escándalos de
este tipo en el país
esta comisión viene investigando los
casos en las diferentes diócesis del
país y también recolectando los
testimonios que víctimas han dado a
través de una plataforma telefónica el
reporte final de esta comisión será
entregado el próximo mes de septiembre
[Música]
el tema de los abusos eclesiásticos en
chile- que marcó los titulares hace unos
años sigue siendo uno de los que sigue
pendiente de justicia en el país el
pasado miércoles el papá francisco
nombraba como miembro de la comisión del
vaticano para la protección de los
abusos a menores a juan carlos cruz una
de las tres víctimas más conocidas del
sacerdote pederasta más icónico en el
país fernando karadima cruz afirmó
sentirse feliz por este cargo que
ejercerá durante tres años y que
refuerza su intención de luchar contra
el flagelo de los abusos y exigir
justicia por su parte la red de
sobrevivientes de abusos secretas ticos
denuncia que en el ministerio público
del país existen al menos 300 casos en
torno a este tema y que sólo una decena
de ellos ha recibido una resolución en
un sentido o en otro con algunos casos
icónicos en los que se ha sobreseído a
los sacerdotes por prescripción de los
delitos que ocurrieron hace muchos años
por su parte la iglesia ha expulsado de
sus filas en los últimos meses a un
puñado de sacerdotes por considerar
probados los hechos
[Música]
desde 1992 cuando el boston globe
publicó un reporte extenso sobre el
encubrimiento de abusos sexuales del
clero en la iglesia católica romana en
eeuu se han disparado los alegatos de
estos crímenes de obispos contra menores
de edad en este país de hecho según la
página bishop accountability org en eeuu
seis mil 721 obispos han sido acusados
de abuso sexual entre 1950 y 2016 además
según la estimación que hace la
conferencia de obispos católicos de eeuu
320 mil niños han sido víctimas de abuso
sexual a pesar de la dificultad en
contabilizar estos casos se calcula
además que la iglesia católica ha tenido
que pagar cerca de 3.200 millones de
dólares para resolver casos de abuso
sexual en su iglesia un problema que
seguramente ha afectado el hecho de que
la proporción de estadounidenses que se
considera miembro de alguna iglesia
sinagoga o mezquita está por debajo del
50% por primera vez
[Música]